[Music]
did you ever see
aie did you
ever go way
and
Theo Theo when Theo was born I couldn't
even hold
him okay I was afraid I was going to
drop
him I'm a terrible mother you're a
wonderful
mother and a wonderful
friend I just want you to be happy
too Max Max get down it's not safe
Max did you ever see
a yep Max is
gone wasn't easy bringing you into this
world now you've left it too
soon you need to separate the free from
the guilt what guilt
Alice something's broken inside of me
and I need
you I saw the look in her eyes she
thinks that I should have saved her son
is that coming from her or you you think
I'm imagining
things we're not going down this path
again you're
right God knows I can get carried away
sometimes
can Theo come over for a little bit it's
amazing how quickly you forgot my son
our
son it helps me to spend time with Theo
but it helps him too do you miss
him's my friend the balcony P wrong did
you did you put Theo on that balcony to
test me do you think I'm capable of
that she wants us to pay for
Max you're just accusing me of things
some kind of monster you're losing touch
with reality leave my family
alone not imagining
[Music]
than what